well the Dutch government is calling for
a global fund in a bid to plug the
shortfall after Trump's abortion ban
let's get the details we are doing now
by Liliana blumen Minister for foreign
trade and development cooperation for
the Netherlands government in The Hague
thank you very much for being with us
this afternoon
good afternoon how would this Global
Fund that the Dutch government is
calling for work well what we're doing
now we're reaching out to countries that
we know are very much interested in
women's rights governments that fund
women's rights to foundations to ask
them to contribute to make sure that we
can fund that the gap that is left
behind by a Global gag rule that
President Trump has now ordered and so
it's a joint effort and we do hope that
we will be able to continue to support
women because it's not only about
abortion it's about much more it's also
about a sexual education it's about
access to contraceptives it's about
helping women who are pregnant giving
them information so it's a lot of
services that are a very dear to women
and girls that are affected by this
global gap rule are you worried that
this effort could provoke tensions with
the United States and are you preparing
for that potential backlash well listen
this is not about politics it's about
the rights of women and girls and so our
government has always been standing very
firm for the rights of women and girls
in our own country but also in other
countries and so this comes very natural
to us and it's something where we feel
we need to need to be off of help
basically to all those organizations
that are affected where do you expect
the bulk of the money for the fun to
come from and has there been any
interest already expressed that you can
tell us about
yeah there's a lot of interest we get
many many calls and and mails from
citizens from many many countries in the
world who want to contribute but we're
also talking of course to governments
and so for example the Belgian
government already announced that they
are supporting this initiative and we
expect some more to come today and
tomorrow we're also talking to
international foundations and we hope
that they will also contribute so there
will be multiple sources and of course
everyone is invited to join and and help
rich that funding yeah we want to thank
you very much for telling us a little
bit more about that funding Liliana
blumen Minister for foreign trade and
development cooperation for the
Netherlands